quand on vous excuser regarder ce n'est
pas la tour eiffel ce n'est pas les
champs elysées ce n'est pas un quartier
de paris
c'est trop beaucoup trop long qu'on a à
tokyo voit la fin du suspense vous le
savez déjà de toute manière et
aujourd'hui on va aller voir des bambi
sur l'île des bombes s'appelle comment
déjà mis à jima le nom voilà oui j'ai
fait inquiète j'ai dû le chercher au
bout sur nous elle est où je me
souvenais plus jouer mais avant un court
extrait de télé japonaise du téléachat
inversement de la chanson mail ces puces
étaient toujours au japon pendant le
congé à l'intelligence à tous sauf qu'en
sais tu as pu vraiment l' inverse de la
france
voilà voilà quatre ans ne voit pas juste
on dit a acheté là est vraiment bien
la j pop dance médicaments tout à fait
ça que moi j'en au japon mais maintenant
avoir des buts un bambi c'est parti
c'est qu'il ne souhaitait pas commenter
ricard et manger dans l'espace dans une
fusée ça n'a pas du tout la gueule d'un
tgv parti kadima japonais se retrouve
quelques instruments géants en train de
faire et 4 passes actuellement sur le
bateau bonjour bambi comment ça va il
s'en bat les steaks de ma vidéo ça va on
prend j'ai envie de le toucher mais je
n'ose pas trop je vous avoue daytona
tête un policier
il se lève il est en train de voler la
bouffe des gens voient ce bon bilan
respecte personne ne veut pas de nous
mais il veut carrément tombé j'ai trouvé
jean michel pause ils mangent en fête du
biou d'argent plein on passe très mal
poli ce qu'on fait
il ya moyen de le faire rentrer dans le
sac à dos foot je propose un petit
restaurant sa part sur une fin en fait
ici les plaçons en version silicone
caoutchouc dans des vitrines pour
vraiment bien pré visualiser ce que tu
vas manger
avec bien évidemment des petites
figurines kawaii un peu partout mais ça
a l'air délicieux je me rends
actuellement dans un bar à ibou et
hachoud es tu as regardé une bonne jouer
tu as on va la voir en vrai dans deux
secondes
symbole de la sagesse en pleine nature
regardez sur la mer soit le cas
je crois qu'elle est chouette de harry
potter
bonjour pourra continuer à y voir qu
accepter aussi docile
par contre beaucoup moins bon c'est ça
ceci est dégueulasse ne jamais jouer
aujourd'hui avocat
c'est sûr qu'il ya la caméra n'a plus
patrice lapierre pas de patrie du monde
mais regardez mon petit bébé elle
regarde les gens dans le métro et sur
ceux ci la big mama des chouettes des
plus grosses du helmand ce qui est très
dur a tenté un fai soit propre à naxos
ici ce sont les hommes qui tirent les
brouettes et bond l'agent s'il ya besoin
de cette vidéo sur cette île mais yajima
voilà jusqu'à la fin de la vidéo
j'aurais boguey c'était splendide
regarder on se quitte sur un petit
coucher de soleil c'était un moment
génial les chouettes sont vraiment très
docile très très mignonne et a fait un
peu flipper quand même ce qu'annonce des
petits scarface un bon se refera de
trois petits blocs comme ça j'espère
c'est vous des paysages bien que ça vous
fait plaisir de découvrir d'autres
endroits ça se grattent par ici c'est le
cas n'hésitez pas à bérive deux purs
seront très bientôt dans une prochaine
vidéo mais ça
oh